thank you for
making a show about wrestling that even
i is someone who only knows the
basics can enjoy i appreciate that
thank you i i am fully of the belief
that genre doesn't matter if you tell a
great story with great
characters in a full world and i feel
like watching the show really
proves that because i really don't know
much of anything about wrestling
amen i'm so happy to hear you say that i
thought
i think we all felt the same way when we
read the scripts at the end of the day
at the heart of any great story it comes
down to character
yeah well steven because you came to the
show
as such a fan of wrestling yourself
was your bar set that much higher for
what you wanted it to be
and what you wanted it to continue to
want to evolve into
from an evolutionary perspective i i
haven't really thought about that
i mean we're still trying to bring the
first season to the world
um but i mean
my goal after reading the scripts
was to just put what was on the page on
the screen
um in the way that i saw it making my
mind's eye
and i think we did that you know i think
that i think that we
we created a really rich world that um
you know is a love letter to
professional wrestling and the men and
women
who who do it removed from the spotlight
and the glitz and the glamour
of wwe or aew um
you know it's it's it's shining a light
on
a really important and integral part of
professional wrestling that not a lot of
people know about so
um i think we did a good job and you
know but time will tell
alex what made you want to take on ace
what was it about him
as a character that made him appealing
to you was it
that he is so flawed absolutely
you know you hit it on the head it's why
i had to interrupt for a second it was
just
i'm so happy to hear this because i hear
this time and time again like i don't
know a lot about wrestling but i love
this show
and i agree it's it's at the heart of
any story is characters that you can see
yourself
in i mean who can't relate to busting
their ass to put food on the table
for their family or wanting more out of
life um why i loved ace so much
and i was so grateful that when i the
offer had come in i was like this is
a character i have wanted to play my
whole life you know this guy is just i
see myself in him in so many different
ways
um he's just an explosive personality in
comparison but
but you know he's just an elevated
version of of these emotions that i've
felt for sure and
um i've just loved what a rollercoaster
of emotions he is
and when you take a character who's so
uh colorful
and then put him in a world that's even
more colorful um i think you're
you're onto something really really
special
you've both come off of shows that were
really physical with arrow and
vikings how does the physicality and the
stunt work that you have to do on
heels compared to what you've done
previously
did any of your past work prepare you
for this or is this
very different i don't think that
anything but nothing prepares you for
professional wrestling
it's a one-of-one experience nothing
prepares you for hitting the ropes
nothing prepares you for to just that
that first time you get in the middle of
the ring
and then go all right fall down
what fall down hit the mat
hard except don't get up with a
concussion
so you know there there there there's so
many
tricks and things that you can do i mean
you know alexander on vikings with the
with that wardrobe and
you know with the big battle scenes the
utilization of doubles and stunt doubles
and stuff like that
same same for me with an arrow suit with
a hood and a mask on
um there's no hiding in in the wrestling
ring it's
it's a it is an incredibly unique
experience
and um you know i i think that
before anyone comments on it they should
just do those two things in a wrestling
ring and see how it feels
yeah how was it for you alexander i mean
this seems like very different
it's not work [ __ ] yeah i got my bell
rung i mean
the first time i hit those ropes and i
did a flat back bump i was just like
whoa there's nothing fake about this
except for the story lines and even that
can go haywire
that's what's so exciting about the show
is that you get to explore that what
happens when you don't follow
the the storylines that were set forth
you know it's a live performance but at
the end of the day the athleticism
that's required
um for your body to withstand
such like abuse is uh
is incredible and i mean we trained more
than anything uh i've trained i trained
more for this than i have for anything
um and this was certainly the most
physically demanding um
but as steven said you know there's no
fakiness i mean we did all the stunts
um we had an incredible stunt team that
came in and educated us
and that was there when we needed them
you know but you know i would say 90
of this um we ended up having to do and
um we needed to do right by the
wrestling community and i have
such huge respect for them because let
me tell you
after ten five to ten minutes in that
ring i i am
heaving i'm gassed i i can't imagine 40
minutes in this ring
and then they're doing it night after
night after night hundreds of days out
of the year it's just
unbelievable since brothers
love and hate each other what what do
your characters most admire
about each other and what are they most
envious about with each other
i think jack's probably jealous of aces
hair
and i think that the thing that he
probably hates about him most is um
i don't i don't think he likes his
wardrobe personally i think i think he's
probably like
ace like really like jerseys okay
you're a grown man just get it together
i think um ace when he looks at jack he
sees this uh
macro mindset you know if if you were
going to put this in
into you know terms of people that are
actually live like jack's on his way to
becoming vince mcmahon
you know ace is on his way to becoming
sean michaels whether or not that
happens is
uh is up to the the story line but i
think that
um um jack has such a macro
sense whereas ace is so impulsive and
emotional
that sometimes he just sees red and he
can't see beyond that
do you guys feel like you hit a very
brotherly groove with each other
pretty quickly yeah yeah
yeah alex alexander's my dude you just
we got along straight away we started
working together
um you know and and and i i think
both of us have experienced appreciate
and understand
that there's no there's no easy way to
to do a tv show
you have to be prepared and you have to
you have to be what your scene partner
needs you to be
whatever that is that was kind of both
of our mindset was like
we both knew we had to give our all to
earn the respect of the wrestling
community
but regardless like i i don't i don't
have to like you on a film set and
stephen's the same way just show up and
do your [ __ ]
the fact that i loved stephen was just
was just incredible and and
there was an element to this that really
blew me away that i didn't expect and
that was the kind of trust
that you have to have in another actor
when you're doing these stunts because
if i'm suplexing steven or or in reverse
we need to make sure that we're not
going to drop each other on our heads
you know and and that bond carried out
outside of the ring
and steven's family to me and he always
will be
how do you guys feel about spandex now
do you have a new appreciation
for spandex do you have a deep hatred
for spandex yeah
yeah no skipping leg day um i've always
loved it and frankly i've been looking
for an excuse to wear it
more often so you know
i'm good i'm good bring it on
seems like it'll raise the expectations
for halloween
yeah that's when you know you made it
you got a bunch of people on halloween
dressing up
in spandex um our our uh our costume
designer um
laura laura bauer was was just
phenomenal on this though i mean
once you put all that stuff on you you
enter the ring i mean you really feel
like you're in the world
is there a real wrestler that either one
of you or both of you would like to have
come to a guest spot on the show
oh man i've been begging adam copeland
um because he was just so
he's a friend of mine and he's um you
know he's one of the greatest heels of
all time
he's in the hall of fame and i leaned on
him a lot just in preparation for this
uh he was edge so i i've been like adam
man
we gotta have you on the show we'd be so
lucky to have you so hopefully if this
continues i would love
love for him to come on well we're not
paying him anything
uh give me god give me um
give me becky lynch becky lynch i'd love
to have becky on the show
well awesome thank you guys i i
definitely love the female characters on
the show too so i think
more of that is also yeah yeah yeah
thank you so much for talking about it
thank you